russian president vladimir putin wanted
to contain nato but since the war broke
out in ukraine we've been hearing a lot
of this he wants less nato he's getting
more nato he wanted to divide those is
getting more united alliance and that is
certainly true just a few years ago the
north atlantic treaty organization which
was created after world war ii to serve
as a check on soviet expansion was
struggling to portray a united front
tonight there is worldwide fallout after
president trump once again raised doubts
about his commitment to nato macron said
nato was experiencing quote brain death
now putin's invasion of ukraine hasn't
just strengthened the bond of nato
countries or their commitment to article
5 which stipulates that an attack on one
is an attack on all putin's war is
actually making the alliance stronger in
tangible ways particularly on its
eastern flank in the country's closest
to russia
here are three ways that nato has
responded to the war in ukraine first
the alliance is significantly upgrading
its arsenal of weapons one way this is
happening is through increased defense
spending germany is the most notable
example pledging to almost double what
it was spending before the war it has
already announced that it wants to buy
state-of-the-art drones from israel and
f-35 warplanes from the u.s to deter
russian nuclear threats poland and
estonia have also pledged to spend more
while other members are currently
hashing out new spending proposals
another way nato members are upgrading
their arsenals is through their huge
operation to resupply ukrainian forces
as nato countries funnel weapons and
supplies to ukraine many are seeking the
latest and greatest us-made weapons to
refill their depleted stockpiles one
example of this so-called upgrading is
slovakia the country already received
american-made patriot air defense
systems from germany and the netherlands
so that it could send its soviet-era
s-300 air defense systems to ukraine
secondly nato has responded to the war
with more boots on the ground nato
didn't deploy combat troops to the
eastern part of the alliance until
russia annexed crimea in 2014 but in
response to what nato calls russian
aggression it created four multinational
battle groups in estonia latvia
lithuania and poland now due to russia's
invasion of ukraine the alliance has
agreed to add four more adding battle
groups in bulgaria hungary romania and
slovakia but here's the thing nato says
these troops are rotating and therefore
not considered permanent
now that could change
so far nato hasn't permanently based
troops on the eastern flank because a
quarter century ago nato and russia
struck an agreement per the nato-russia
founding act nato said it wouldn't put
troops in its new eastern members and
nato and russia committed not to
threaten each other use force against
each other or use force against any
other state its sovereignty territorial
integrity or political independence now
that russia has invaded ukraine western
officials say that agreement is
nullified and that the alliance can put
troops wherever it sees fit and last but
not least as a result of this war nato
could expand even further
in the officially neutral countries of
finland and sweden polls show that for
the very first time a majority of the
populations support joining the alliance
we have a change situation in
both in
finland and sweden this is something we
are now
open to a discussion with our parliament
finland shares the european union's
longest border with russia so it has
tried to avoid antagonizing moscow but
russia's invasion of ukraine has alarmed
the population russia has explicitly
warned finland and sweden not to join
nato nevertheless the two countries both
participated in an emergency nato
meeting in march
so nato is clearly getting stronger but
one country that's unlikely to join
anytime soon ukraine countries that want
to join must meet strict criteria and
ukraine is far from meeting those
requirements in recent weeks ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky has
acknowledged that ukraine is unlikely to
become a nato member anytime soon if you
thought this piece was informative hit
the like button and subscribe to the
channel for more stories like this i'll
see you soon